if you want to better understand
yourself and how to better interact with
others
you need to understand your values
that's why the minimalist created a
free downloadable and printable values
worksheet
that will help you identify all of your
different values
and the obstacles that are in your way
head on over to theminimalists.com
v to download your free values worksheet
today
enjoy as a manager
i feel obligated to attend after hours
networking events usually happy hours
that my
employer hosts i i saw that as my
emperor hosts
my manager is manger so there's all
kinds of stuff going on here
i have social anxiety and do not drink
so these events
have led to panic attacks on more than
one occasion
how do i permanently say no without
risking my job
step one actually i haven't i have a
story
yeah um i had a
i had a bunch of employees at a certain
point
and i threw a christmas party because
that's what i thought
good managers did their christmas
parties and there was i probably had
like i don't know 15 or 20 employees
and um like
i i expected everyone to be there and i
didn't even in my head i didn't think it
was mandatory i just expected everyone
to be there
yeah but then like five of them were
like uh
yeah we're not we're not coming and i'm
like why can't how can you not come like
it's gonna be a good time blah blah blah
blah they're like
they're like my job is to sell cell
phones my job is not to come to your
christmas party
yeah and i was like sorry i scheduled
you for this party you have to be here
right
but you know what they're absolutely
right yes and that's how i saw i was
like oh they got they
they have a very good point like i'm not
my feelings aren't going to be hurt
because they don't want to associate
with me
any more than they have to like that's
not they're not obligated to associate
with me so
that's i mean answering this question
head on for jessica
jessica you are not obligated to go to
these things and if they make you feel
guilty about it like that's
that's them projecting their own guilt
yes that has nothing to do with you
stop going to the freaking parties and
even if you're obligated meaning like
they require it
you're still not obligated there are
always other options
and if and i mean let's take it to the
like to the extreme let's say they fire
you they find some way to fire you
because you're not associating with them
great
they're forcing you into finding a
better situation because right now
if that's the case they're gonna fire
you for they're gonna like be like well
she's on a team player and we're gonna
like find some
oh you came in five minutes late you're
fired whatever it is yeah
uh what i hear them saying is is that
they expect you to show up
have anxiety attacks with no unders
without any compassion for you
um and if you don't do that you're fired
which you don't want to work through any
way if that's the case
you talk about toxic expectations right
and by the way i would say all
expectations are toxic to some degree
sure but what we're talking about here
is like a high degree of toxicity
if you don't come to my christmas party
i will think poorly of you
yeah what a yeah that's a toxic
environment